Hey, Vsauce. Michael here. And today we're
going to discuss déjà vu. What is it, and
why does it occur? You know, those moments
where the current situation feels like it's
happened before? You're certain it has, but
you don't know when, or how it became so familiar.
It's difficult to scientifically study déjà vu because there's no reliable way to cause
it to happen in people's heads in a laboratory.
But here's what we do know: humans don't seem
to experience déjà vu until they're at least
8 or 9 years old. It's most frequent in your
teens and twenties, and then tapers off as
you get older. So, it might have something
to do with brain development. In fact, we
should probably go get ourselves a brain.
That was easy. Now, like a stomach ache, déjà
vu may be a symptom with many possible causes.
A lot of the popular theories about what causes
it involve a disconnect that may be occurring
between the deep structures of the brain that
process our experiences unconsciously, and
the parts of the brain that are conscious
of what they experience, process it, and
then tell us what we're seeing.
For the sake of simplicity, let's begin with
the visual system. Now, the brain sits in
your head like this, and your eyeballs are
over here seeing things, sending that signal
to the back of the brain, the Occipital lobe,
where visual cortex is. That's where the image
is processed and we become aware of what we're
seeing. But visual cortex isn't the first
stop that information makes. Instead, we know
that it stops in lots of other places. For
instance, the amygdala, where it may be processed
at an involuntary emotional level, and this
fun little part right here, #31, the tectum.
It's involved in preliminary visual processing
and helps control eye movements.
Now, that fact is incredibly important because
what it means is that people with blindness
caused by brain damage to the visual cortex
cannot see anything. They don't report seeing
or recognizing anything; however, the other
preliminary parts of the brain that get that
message are still healthy, and so, despite
being legally blind, these people exhibit
what is known as blindsight.
They can defy all odds and avoid an obstacle
course on the ground. They can also be presented
faces showing joy, or anxiety and fear, and
feel, without knowing why, at all, on Earth they feel
that way, a similar emotion.
So, a lot is going on when we look at things,
and if those preliminary structures in the
vision system allow certain blind people to
be oddly and unconsciously aware of what they're
looking at, we may have the ingredients we
need for this disconnect.
Think of it this way. If I experience event
A and then B and then C, and the inner parts
of my brain commit it to memory and generate
an emotional response, but then, a fraction
of a second later, out-of-sync, my visual
cortex finally gets around to telling me,
the conscious aware part of my brain, what
I'm seeing. It will say "Ok guys, we're looking
at A, and then B, and then..." and then the
brain says "Whoa, whoa, whoa, wait, wait,
and then C, right? That's already happened
I thought?..." and that may be déjà vu.
But what could cause these processes, dealing
with the same information, to get temporarily
out-of-sync like that? Well, it's probably
a neurological abnormality, possibly an epileptic
episode where neurons all fire in sync. We
also know that patients who experience chronic
and persistent déjà vu tend to have brain
damage in the temporal lobes of their brain -
these lobes on either side.
Well that sounds kinda bad, right? I mean, when I
experience déjà vu, should I run to the doctor
right away? Well, not at all. In fact, minor
epileptic events are quite common. You've
probably experienced a similar phenomenon
known as a Hypnagogic Jerk. That's a fancy
name for what occurs when you're about to
fall asleep and then all of the sudden you
feel like you're falling, or that you tripped,
and your body jolts itself awake.
What's going on there is that as you fall
asleep your muscles relax, and some part of
your brain that's still awake notices that,
and feels like you're no longer supported -
you must be falling - and it sends out a huge
signal that causes all of your muscles to
twitch, waking you up.
Oh, and déjà vu is not the only "vu" out there.
There's also something known as Presque vu,
or "tip of the tongue," and this is what happens
when you're familiar with something, you know
you know it, but, for the life of you, at that
moment, you cannot recall it. It's like "what's
that actor's name from that movie? I've seen
it 18 times, how can I not remember it? Wow."
One explanation of how that happens is that
other words similar to the target word are
being remembered, and to help you out your
brain is actively blocking other stuff around
it, including the word you're actually looking
for. Now, this explanation is really nice
'cause it might actually explain why Presque
vu has a shared or social aspect. Even a
bunch of people in a group, all with separate
brains, if they're given the same "blocking
words" that are related, no one in the group
can come up with the name until the subject
is changed and those words are no longer blocked,
and then all the sudden someone goes "Oh,
Gary Sinise, that's who it was. Yup, there
you go."
Ok, finally, Jamais vu. This is when something
that you know, something that you're familiar
with, all of a sudden seems brand new and bizarre.
Schizophrenic patients will sometimes see
people they know and insist that it's not
the person they know. Instead, it's an imposter.
But all of us have probably experienced Jamais
vu to a certain extent, for instance, when
you repeat a word over, and over, and over,
and over again, the word starts to lose its
meaning and you start to think "What? How
is this even a word? It's so weird!" Well,
scientists believe that happens because continuing
to excite the neurons responsible for that
word causes them to become inhibited, and
further use is less intense.
It is just crazy to think that there is so
much out there in the world, in the universe,
that we don't know, that we don't understand,
that we haven't yet discovered. But yet
that very feeling of familiarity for what
we do know can't always be trusted. About
the only constant seems to be:
As always,
thanks for watching.